so I've seen a lot of text up here and
then I noticed hey there's a Gibson
guitar ten what type of tech stuff could
they possibly have Bart Walsh is about
to blow your frigging mind
so what we have here is the first
robotic guitar Chris I don't know how
many times it has happened to you but
the house is sold out there's a million
ciao ready a zero times theoretically
sold out and you know you get ready to
your big moment on stage and you hear
this now must recognize that have an
out-of-tune guitar cool it's a
career-ending moment yeah you know that
sounded good to me maybe that's why I
don't sell out shows all I have to do is
pull out this knob here then press the
center turns red strum the strings and
the guitar is now tuning itself you can
see the Machine had some telekinetic and
telekinetic excellence so that was the
robot that was the robots circuitry
working right there you didn't have to
do anything so besides sucking at guitar
which a lot of people do including
myself the other main thing that sucks
about guitar is having the tune it so
this completely takes care of that
problem for you never have to tune a
guitar again the ever and it code
through seven presets all for tuning so
you can write your own tunings yeah and
it eliminates a lot of the hassles so
you're you know more free to create and
this will bring groupies to orgasm as
well so this is really the perfect
package I think way to go Gibson thanks
Bart
you